>> Edge Detection is a technique that uses
filters to find abrupt changes of pixel values,
which often indicate the boundaries of
shapes or objects in the image.
To begin, we convert color images to grayscale,
so that we're only dealing with a single channel of pixels.
Then, we apply particular type of filter called a Sobel Filter,
after one of its inventors, Irwin Sobel,
along with his colleague, Gary Feldman,
conceived of the idea of using
a three-by-three filter to find gradients in images.
The technique is performed in two stages.
First, this kernel is
applied to find the horizontal gradient for each pixel,
let's call that Gx.
Then, this kernel is applied to detect the vertical gradients,
which we'll call Gy.
Then, we just add the squares of the x and
y gradient values calculated for each pixel,
and take the square root to determine
the length of the vector described by the pixels.
Then, we can calculate
the inverse tangent of those values to determine its angle.
That will reveal the edges in the image.